[Musique]
professeur gérard lasfargues
bonjourbonjour directeur général délégué
pour les sciences pour l' expertise à
lens s l'agencé nationale de sécurité
sanitaire sécurité sanitaire ce terme
est important donc l' agence nationale
de sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation
de l'environnement et du travail alors
appelez nous brièvement les principales
missions de l'ansès vous travaillez
beaucoup sur les expositions de l'homme
face à toutes les sources de pollution
de contamination possible chimiques
biologiques voire même radiofréquences
enfin les ondes là qui se baladent dans
exactement exactement notre mission
principale c'est effectivement d'évaluer
les risques que peuvent courir les
citoyens dans leurs rangs viennent nous
prendre en général mais aussi les
travailleurs dans l'environnement
professionnel
et puis bien évidemment les
consommateurs à travers l'alimentation
est par exemple la contamination
chimique des aliments et à partir de là
nous fournissons des avis des
recommandations qui vont permettre aux
autorités publiques aux autorités
sanitaires de prendre les décisions
évidemment les plus appropriées pour
protéger la population alors une des
recommandations délivrées par lan cesse
a défrayé la chronique a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre on utilisera le terme
congo qu'on veut mais enfin ça c'était
en tout début de cette année 2010 8 ça a
suscité un certain émoi aux antilles
parce que il y avait une recommandation
concernant l'alimentation et les limites
maximales résident résidus de
chlordécone notamment dans la viande
clairement je alors où en est-on
aujourd'hui après tout cette nous sommes
désolés si la vie de lindsay ça a été
mal compris
à ce moment là je veux être très clair
là dessus le président de la république
quand il est passé et son passage a été
marquant il
il a parlé de scandale environnemental à
propos de la chlordécone
aujourd'hui il a bien dit que les
contrôles dans l'alimentation serait
renforcée et la paix il a préconisé un
habillement un abaissement des seuils
réglementaires
conformément aux recommandations de
landes cesse et c'est effectivement ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui puisque
nous avons déjà fourni un avis et des
recommandations pour ramener la limite
maximale de résidus dans les viandes
bovines à à 20 microgrammes par kilo et
nous avons maintenant été saisie par le
ministère de l'agriculture pour pouvoir
réviser les autres limites maximales de
résidus dans les autres types de viandes
notamment donc là dessus je vois gevrey
lever toute ambiguïté par rapport à sa
mêlée mais l'essentiel n'est pas là
l'essentiel pour nous c'est de protéger
la population et donc c'est la priorité
est à la réduction des expositions à la
chlordécone et qu'est-ce qu'ils
s'exposent c'est parce que l'opinion
publique avait compris justement à la
suite de cette recommandation
voilà donc je veux corriger corriger le
tir exactement mais c'est important de
le d'insister là dessus de le répéter
voilà voilà voilà les les expressions
concernant tout ce qui concerne les
risques sanitaires sont parfois
difficiles voilà parce que c'est le
scientifique sur la glace il n'y a pas
eu de fumée sans feu quand même en début
d'année c'est bien il y avait bien une
sorte de se passer c'est une directive
européenne mais une recommandation en
tout cas au niveau des limites maximales
de résidus sont fixés au niveau
oui voilà la haye et mais nous notre si
vous avez une autonomie par rapport à ça
une marche à suivre en tout temps une
agence indépendante directive européenne
nous sommes une agence indépendante nous
ce que nous fixons ce sont les valeurs
toxicologiques de référence c'est-à-dire
la quantité de chlordécone que les gens
seraient susceptibles d'ingérer et qui
pourrait amener un risque sanitaire donc
donc nous fixions ce seuil la voilà
le travail sur les limites maximales de
résidus la fixation c'est la commission
européenne ce et ministère de
l'agriculture ce n'est pas mais ils
peuvent s'appuyer sur nous les éléments
que nous fournissons en matière de
valeurs toxicologiques de référence est
pour nous la priorité aujourd'hui c'est
clairement la réduction des expositions
et ça on la montre est bien dans le
colloque on a restitué les résultats de
notre grande enquête canaris qui
montrent que les personnes qui sont les
plus exposés aujourd'hui la chlordécone
sont celles qui s'alimentent dans les
circuits dits informels non contrôlés
pour lesquels les maires ne ne sont pas
en vigueur c'est ça qu'on a voulu me
mettre en avant
et c'est très important parce que il
faut vraiment aujourd'hui que ces
populations soient soient protégés quand
on regarde par exemple les volailles ou
les yeux qui sont produites dans les
poulaillers en zone non contaminée dans
les yeux vous pouvez avoir mille fois
plus de chlordécone que dans les autres
aliments donc c'est pour nous la
priorité elle est là voilà ça veut pas
du tout dire qu'il faut stigmatiser ces
circuits informels c'est quelque chose
qui est très très important en
martinique l'alimentation donc le
circuit informel faudra plessé c'est
donc le les petits commerces eux les
personnes qui disent les légumes dans
leurs gènes dans leur jardin créole
jardins particuliers qui osa notamment
vont troquer avec le voisin ou à lille
dont les jambes ça fait partie du mode
de vie martinique et qu'il faut
éminemment respecté parce que d'abord ça
permet aux gens de consommer des fruits
des légumes du poisson tout ça c'est
excellent sur le plan nutritionnel ça a
été montré et donc donc ça continuer à
le faire mais ça il faut continuer à
faire les règles quand même mais il faut
qu'on aille compagne les personnes
notamment celles qui produisent dans
leur jardin
pour que évidemment elle puisse produire
des soit d'aider des commandes des
denrées qu'ils ne soient pas contaminés
et puis compliqué puis à avoir des
diagnostics fait c'est à dire que les
gens aujourd'hui peuvent demander à ce
qu'on examine qu'on fasse des
prélèvements pour voir si leur jardin
est contaminée et puis qu'on trouve des
solutions les programmes dits jaffa d'un
de jardin donc fin de you ou bien marché
aujourd'hui si vous regardez la
concentration en chlordécone dans les
légumes racines et des tubercules elle
elle est au même niveau que ce que vous
achetez en zone contrôlée dans les
supermarchés etc
donc ça marche on l'a simplement
aujourd'hui il faut considérablement
renforcé ses actions et notamment
focalisée aussi sur ce qui est
poulailler et c'est pour aider les gens
de façon à ce qu'ils puissent continuer
ce type de production et d'alimentation
qui est importante
alors c'est là tout le sens tout le
contenu finalement de ce que vous avez
commencé à communiquer voilà que vous
allez continuer dans le cadre de ce
colloque
absolument toutes ces choses là on les a
pas dit par hasard un l'étude canaries
c'est plus de dix mille prélèvements
d'échantillons alimentaires que nous
avons analysé c'est la plus grosse étude
sur ce plan là et nous allons évidemment
continuer aujourd'hui ce que l'on
souhaiterait faire c'est ce qu'on
appelle les enquêtes d'alimentation
total ce qu'on a déjà fait en france
pour la population adulte et pour la
population enfants il s'agit d'analyser
tous les continents
cam tous les contaminants chimiques
possible de l'alimentation dans le cadre
de ses études d'alimentation total nous
avons par exemple pour la population des
enfants en france analysé plus de 600
contaminants chimiques plus de 200
pesticides dans l'alimentation
voilà le résultat c'est ça montre quand
même que l'alimentation des français de
façon générale est plutôt saine part
alors à beaucoup d'aliments et amar
compte nous voulons le faire aujourd'hui
en martinique
parce que il ya des spécificités
alimentaire
et nous voulons faire je dirais plus
encore avec les martiniquais parce que
nous avons besoin et c'est eux qui
savent qu'ils le savent ce sont les
acteurs locaux
nous avons besoin de bien connaître
voilà les habitudes alimentaires les
modes d'alimentation pour pouvoir
ajuster le protocole et donc nous
construirons ce protocole d'étude avec
les martiniquais eux mêmes c'est
vraiment de la science participative que
l'on veut ferris gérard lasfargues
directeur
délégué à lens s on parle beaucoup de la
chlordécone mais il y a plein d'autres
pesticides et il ya une dépêche d'hier
qui indique par exemple que l'on cesse a
annoncé le réexamen de l'autorisation
des pesticides à base de méthane sodium
ou ça doit vous dire quelque chose
à la suite de plusieurs intoxications
intervenues ces derniers jours dans le
maine et loire
et donc voilà est par exemple ça ça
continue d'être utilisée sur le
territoire français mettent en sodium
utilisé dans lesquelles le cultures
maraîchères comme la marche alors c'est
peut-être le cas aussi en martinique
gens gentils rien dans nos cultures
maraîchères attendait juste quelques
secondes
le méthane sodium présente des effets
irritants sensibilisant et corrosif pour
la peau les voies respiratoires les yeux
rappel lens s appelle la nes utilisé
pour la désinfection des sols il dégage
un gaz qui tue les champignons les
insectes les herbes et les verts bref et
encore du pain sur la planche
aller et il faut pas se focaliser même
chez nous sur une liaison la la
chlordécone bien sûr vous avez
complètement raison
du côté de l' agence nous avons deux
grands types d'actions d'une part pour
les autorisations de mise sur le marché
évidemment nous évaluons les risques des
produits pesticides avant leur
autorisation de mise sur le marché pour
les travailleurs pour le consommateur
pour les riverains par exemple de
parcelles agricoles et nous écartons
bien entendu d'emblée les pesticides qui
pourraient être des cancérogènes avérés
même probable des reprotoxiques bien
entendu après il n'en reste pas moins
voilà que beaucoup de substances
chimiques sont aujourd'hui utilisées y
compris encore en agriculture donc là
par rapport à ça nous avons deux types
d'actions d'abord la phyto
pharmacovigilance c'est-à-dire la toxico
vigilance nous exerçons une veille
permanente en recueillant les deux ans
il faudra conclure aux attentes des
professionnels de santé
là-dessus et c'est très important de
faire remonter ces données pour qu'on
puisse retirer les autorisations six
cantons voisins ville nous préconisons
évidemment toutes les méthodes
alternatives avec donc l'apport ici
beaucoup des des scientifiques en
particulier nous avons
l'apport de scientifiques y compris de
la martinique et des antilles sur ce
plan merci merci gérard lasfargues
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
vous participerez cet après-midi les
changes grandes cultures
bien sûr va bien si près parce que je
pense que les gens attendent des
réponses notamment par exemple sur les
maladies professionnelles et c'est très
important de le rapporter
merci bonne journée
[Musique]